please please there's a lot of try to
get through thank you thank you I think
I don't want to thank you I love you bye
mwah mwah I think I know why you're so
excited tonight because a Democrat
almost won an election Alva we are
following this mr. the excitable John a
soft down in Georgia thank you very much
all right like in the theater I need my
line no I I know he's from Georgia I
know where this happened the Democrats
poured a ton of time and money into this
election and he came so close party
leaders are calling it a terrifying
brush with success so yeah now you know
this Donald Trump is the worst person
ever
[Applause]
and he's a Republican and he's president
and yet since he's been president it's
been four special elections Democrats
over four in the Trump era Democrats are
so lame
the Russians are like we were going to
hack this election but why bother
sergej take day off we don't even need
and of course the big excuse is well we
weren't supposed to win
what election are you supposed to win if
you can't win this one you know George's
sixth District where this election took
place the sixth most educated district
in the entire country
this is affluent college educated is the
upscale part of Georgia you can't get
into the Waffle House without a
reservation
it's the upscale Oh guys marry their
sister just for the tax credit is really
really now folks I have to tell you
Democrats have to stop losing elections
because sorry Republican viewers I love
you but the wrong people are in power
and they are not afraid to use that
power and let me tell you they are full
of good ideas as a Republicans this week
a Republican congressman introduced a
bill to make it legal for Senators and
Representatives to carry firearms at
work there at the Capitol which sounds
like a good plan until John McCain cell
phone rings and he answers his gun
and of course there being a real bad
idea and the real bad news this week is
the Senate unveiled their super secret
health care bill like me after the show
it was hashed out behind closed doors
[Laughter]
and you know that everybody think it was
unveiled unveiled is not the right term
you unveil a sculpture nobody goes
behold a turd this is more like
something that was excreted I mean
health care bill more like a manifesto
from the Zodiac killer
they should have published it by cutting
out letters from the newspaper it phases
out Medicaid the safety net for our
oldest poorest and most vulnerable
citizens
it lets States drop the Obamacare
protections like pre-existing conditions
and just for spite it D funds Planned
Parenthood no no more gynecological
exams although Trump says he is still
available to grab [ __ ]
now of course not being one-sided and
leaving out the good part there's a
massive tax cut for the top 1% yes the
guiding principle is rich people if you
like your money you can keep your money
[Music]
and even still I love this a small group
of rebuff thank you one person a small
group of Republican senators say they
can't vote for it because it's not mean
enough a group led by not surprisingly
Ted Cruz who has been studying health
care from top to bottom up and down Ted
says who knows more about making people
sick than I do but do not kid yourself
this will pass Republicans get [ __ ] done
Mitch McConnell says he wants a vote
before the 4th of July when Trump voters
traditionally blow their hands off
oh the fourth of July hey summers here
boy it was real Beach weather in Phoenix
the other day did you see that it was
122 122 plains could not take off hey
climate deniers
if melting IceCaps and rising oceans and
pandemics aren't enough to scare you not
being able to leave Phoenix that should
work
right on cue this week Donald Trump has
a rally in Iowa where he's bragging
about bringing back coal jobs in a state
where there are no coal jobs at Iowa the
state was by far the most wind power
so truck shit's on wind power in Iowa he
says quote I don't want to just hope the
wind blows to light up your homes yes
because that's how wind power work your
lights go on and off depending on
whether the wind is blowing hey say with
solar the Sun goes behind a cloud your
cable goes out
but speaking of solar Donald Trump broke
some news at the rally that the wall you
know the wall between us and Mexico it's
going to have solar panels on he said it
was his idea solar battles okay so the
wall which is never going to be built
which Mexico is never going to be paying
for which now has imaginary so propels
on because if it's one big Donald Trump
AIDS it's fake news